Commander is such a deep and complex
game that challenges you every step of
the way from playing to deck building.
And today we are highlighting a set of
very special cards. They may involve
playing patterns that are extremely
complex or decisions that teach us some
of the fundamentals of the game. This is
Jin with Next Level Commander and today
I bring you eight cards that turn us
into better EDH players. To start things
off, I want to say that we are not
including tutors except one really
really special one. Yes. Well, they are
difficult to play definitely because
they involve massive decision trees. But
if I did that, the list will be full of
tutors. We want something different and
every card kind of covers a different
aspect of playing the game. So, if you
play all eight cards, master them and
you will become an all rounded EDH
player. Yes, this is a guarantee.
Let's start.
Kind of popular, War Room. Yeah, this is
a card that everyone knows about, but
playing it well does require a little
bit of contemplation. It teaches us two
things. First, the importance of mana
sinks. EDH is an intricate game where
often times we just do nothing. Well, in
this case, having something like War
Room at our disposal can be the
difference maker. Another is what I call
the alert of card draw. I find that
often times when I'm under pressure, I
tend to way overestimate the possibility
of drawing a few cards and getting the
perfect answer from that. So then,
instead of making a perfectly reasonable
play with what I have in hand, I'd fire
off a draw spell and mess up the tempo
of my turn and ending up pretty much
wasting a turn not being able to defend
ourselves. So yeah, draw spells are
good, but in a pinch, you should rather
rely on what you currently have than the
unknown. Play with what you have and
reload when you have a moment to
breathe. That should be common sense,
right? Anyways, so War Room is the kind
of card that is good under very specific
circumstances and it can be one of the
best utility lands in your deck if you
learn to find the right timing. Next up,
Dress Down. And I'm not talking about
learning other rules for the potential
interactions, although that also be
quite impressive. But here I'm talking
about patience. With Dress Down, timing
is everything. Drop this to counter a
powerful ETB ability or wait to
potentially counter multiples. Or do we
wait for a board wipe to shut off dying
triggers? Or perhaps take out any
indestructible creature.
Also, if you anticipate a combo in the
horizon, maybe hold because this will
most likely shut it down for a turn.
Waiting for the right timing instead of
being trigger happy is something we must
learn with any answer card in Commander.
But Dress Down actually has another
layer of complexity, being a cantrip.
And like any answer card that also
cantrips, there will be times when you
wonder if you should just cycle it for
another card. And the rule of thumb is
if you have to ask, the answer is
probably yes. Like when you're trying to
hit your fifth land drop. You're in
blue, you need your lands. Cards are
easy to come by and for cantrips, once
you decided to use it, the earlier the
better.
So, between ultimate patience to wait
out the blowout of the century or being
pragmatic and just digging yourselves
closer to another land, the range here
is massive and trying to play this card
optimally will teach us a lot about
control and playing our answers better.
And in a similar vein, Three Steps Ahead
and pretty much any modal spell. But
these three ones are the best for
teaching us modal spells because they're
just so efficient and playable with
almost whatever combination you choose.
When you put these spells into the deck,
you generally envision a default mode
like a one-sided board wipe with Final
Showdown, making five copies of
something and win the game on the spot
with Rite of Replication, and doing
literally everything with Three Steps
Ahead. But the reality is there will be
times when you just need to copy
something once, right now. Or just to
dig two cards deep. And we need to
figure out when those times are and just
go for it. We need to free ourselves off
that default mode and understand that
modal cards are powerful because of the
flexibility and they're only at their
best if we can find the right situation
for every mode.
Next up is a bit of a hidden gem,
Manascape Refractor. In just 8,000 deck
spots, holy, this is a mana rock. With
the amount of insane utility lands being
printed today, Manascape Refractor not
only allows us to borrow their
abilities, but more importantly, it
trains us to be aware of what's lurking
around in the seemingly innocent
resource pools that people are stacking
together. Now, constantly keeping track
is impossible, but just being somewhat
aware, having it register like a ding, a
little, when someone plays a Scavenger
Scourge, can make all the difference.
And this awareness is something
invaluable to have with or without the
Refractor. Next up, I know I said no
tutors, but again, the just this this
this one is really special cuz even
compared to your average tutor, this
card just has so much more play. Court
of Calling.
Being able to potentially get any
creature from your deck into play at
instant speed while tapped out, your
opponent's not expecting it will give
you the chance for the biggest blowouts
and it's up to you to engineer it.
Knowing every available creature in your
deck and how it interacts with the
current board state or stack isn't just
helpful for this particular spell. It's
an important skill to have for every
player who plays a deck with Chord of
Calling.
And moving on to something with a bit
more spice, Catastrophe. Now, this card
I did highlight in my previous video
about mass land destruction, but it
absolutely fits here
as a gateway to land destruction. Be
modal, this card will be a board wipe 80
to 90% of the time, but once in a while
you will find a window where casting
this with the nuclear option straight up
wins you the game. And finding that
window will require the ability to read
the board and your opponent's potential
responses. Important to note though,
when in doubt, just use it as a board
wipe. Only boom the lands if you're
close to 100% sure that it will lead to
game-winning advantage.
Now, of course, you can't play around
everything in Commander, but there are
definitely ways to up your chances. Like
if you suspect someone holding a removal
against your Avacyn, send your Avacyn in
for an attack first to test the waters.
And just by having the nuclear option,
this card teaches us to better read the
game and our opponents while we stay
vigilant waiting for that legendary
window. Next up, Valakut Awakening. Now,
this is the card that teaches us to play
MDFCs. The front side is incredibly
strong, allowing us to do a potential
mulligan, which might get us another
land to replace it. But like we
mentioned earlier, the potential of new
cards is always tempting, but there will
be times when playing this as a land is
correct. And that involves properly
assessing what the average draw from
your deck looks like. No, Valakut
Awakening most likely won't not dig you
into the best card you need right now.
Being able to objectively assess your
hand versus what you may potentially
draw is a very useful skill when playing
red with wheels still being some of the
most powerful cards in your color pie.
And finally, a personal favorite,
Winding Canyons. An all-star utility
land that should be in more decks and is
really cheap for what it is. It's on the
reserve list, I mean. Flash is just such
a powerful utility that is not just for
creatures. Even in spell-heavy decks
with a powerful commander, keep the
choice open between plopping down your
commander or using your mana to answer
something can make a huge difference.
Playing at instant speed has the
potential for massive plays and it keeps
you focused for the entirety of the game
thinking with every play your opponents
make, looking for the right time to pull
the trigger. And that over time will
definitely make you a better player.
And there you have it, eight cards that
are like mini games on their own. They
may seem difficult to master at first,
but will take your gameplay up a level
if you stick with them. This is Jim with
Next Level Commander. Please leave in
the comments what other cards you know
also fall into this category. Like,
subscribe, and I will see you in the
next video.